at a scatterplot and try to understand
you know what exactly is correlation
what does it refer to and you know how
do we find out what exactly it is so
first of all here's some terminology
that applies to correlation it could be
a positive correlation it can be a
negative correlation it could be no
correlation and basically what it is is
we're plotting some points okay these
are scatter plots and we're trying to
figure out if we were trying to draw a
line of best fit you know would that
line have a positive slope meaning going
up to the right would have a negative
slope meaning going down to the right or
would it be relatively no correlation
then if we want to refine it further we
could say well that's a strong positive
correlation what that means strong
positive is the points are very you know
well aligned okay like in a straight
line so that if you were to draw that
line of best fit it would come very very
close to hitting all of those points
that's a strong positive and if it was
you know the points were in an almost a
straight line and it was trending down
with a negative slope that would be a
strong negative and then of course a
weak positive means yeah it's generally
going up but you know it's not really
the points aren't really close to being
in a perfectly straight line
same thing with weak negative so let's
see if we can classify these ones here
and at the end of the video what I'm
going to also do is I'm going to show
you on the calculator how to actually
find out what that our value is okay
they use the R to represent the
correlation coefficient and I'll show
you how that works as well now the other
thing I want to mention is that when you
talk about our values or correlation
coefficients it's on a spectrum from
negative one to one negative one means
that it's a negative correlation it's
going down to the right but that one
means that the points are perfectly in a
straight line okay
same thing with positive when they're
perfectly in a straight line okay but if
it's closer to the middle here at zero
whether it's a negative point one or
positive point one the closer it gets to
zero zero means like there's relatively
no correlation there's not a pattern
it's not really going up to the right
it's not really going down to the right
so basically as you get further to the
ends of the spectrum towards negative 1
or positive 1 the better the points are
aligned in a straight line so let's take
a look so this first one here what would
you say is it a positive negative and
would you say it's a strong pause
strong negative or weak positive weak
negative well if I should draw a line of
best fit it looks like you know it's
trending down to the right okay
definitely maybe kind of like you know
it's okay me I would say probably a weak
negative okay for this one a weak
negative correlation so it's gonna have
a negative our value but it might be
somewhere around you know negative 0.5
or negative 0.6 okay this one here you
can definitely see it's trending up to
the right that's going to have a
positive correlation coefficient okay
positive our value again you know it's
positive but it's going to be like maybe
you know positive 0.5 or maybe a
positive 0.6 okay just estimating now
this one you can see these points are
almost perfectly in a straight line
trending up to the right positive slope
this is definitely gonna be a strong
positive correlation the r-value is
gonna be very very close to one if not
exactly positive one right and then this
one you can see it's hard to really tell
if I was trying to let draw a line of
best fit what I draw it going up to the
right where they go out drawing it down
going down to the right if there's
really relatively no correlation so this
would be no correlation and it would be
very very close to zero okay if not zero
so that's an overview of just how the
correlation coefficients now it works
let's go ahead and take a look at the
graphing calculator and I'm going to
show you how exactly to calculate what
that our value is when you're you know
drawing a line of best fit
okay here we are with the ti-83 graphing
calculator and you can do the same thing
on the ti-84 and some of the other
graphing calculators but let me show you
how this works we're going to try to
find that correlation coefficient and
what the first thing want to do is go
over here to stat for statistics right
so stat and then what you want is edit
enter and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to arrow up to the top of these
lists and I'm just going to hit this
Clear button okay when you do that and
arrow down it's going to clear off that
list same thing over here list one go up
to the top hit clear and then arrow down
so what we're to do is we're going to
put the x coordinates in list one in the
Y coordinates and list two and I've
written down some points here for us so
let's let's just go ahead and reduce Oh
negative 3s for the X negative 1 2 3 & 4
and then if I arrow over here for the Y
coordinates let's see I've written down
negative 2 negative
one let's see negative 1 1 & 4 okay so
now what you want to do is go back to
stat over here stat arrow to the right 4
calculate and what we want is we want a
linear regression number 4 okay see it's
like linear regression like y equals MX
plus B like a slope intercept form of
the line enter okay and you can see what
it's giving us here now is this our
value 0.8 to the equation of our line is
going to be y equals 0.67 X plus a
negative 0.476 okay so you can put the a
and the B and for the equation there but
look at that our value point 8 2 so that
means it's a positive correlation it's
going up to the right and it's pretty
close to 1 which means that you know
this is a pretty you know this is a
pretty good so what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to write down the
equation that line which is y equals 0.8
to 6 let's see oh that's the R value so
we've got let's see y is equal to let's
see point six seven six X plus negative
point four seven six
okay so what we can do now is let's go
back to y equals okay and let's put that
equation in so 0.67 6x okay - point four
seven six and then I'm going to go back
to let's see I'm going to go back to
this second stat plot and see how it's
off I'm going to turn that plot on okay
on because we want to see those data
points and I'm going to select this one
here okay and let's go back to graph up
here in the upper right hand corner so
you can see there's those are our data
points there's our line of best fit and
so you can see some of these points you
know they're a little bit of a distance
away from you know the line but you can
see it's definitely trending up to the
right that's why we have a positive our
value of was about 0.8 and but not too
bad so definitely definitely a
correlation there definitely positive
not exactly perfectly one where they're
in a straight line but but very you know
pretty close to it so that's how you do
it the one last thing I want to mention
is sometimes when you're working with
this correlation coefficient some
calculators they don't automatically
give you that our value what you have to
do is you have to go down here to
catalog C here right above the zero so
what you'd want to do is select second
and catalog and what you want to do is
you want to arrow down to Diagnostics so
I'm just going to hit the letter D here
see if I can find it D right there and
then what you want to do is arrow down
to diagnostic and you want to turn that
on see what it says diagnostic off
diagnostic on enter enter now when you
go to do this linear regression it'll
make sure to give you that our value
otherwise sometimes if you change the
batteries or when you first get the
calculator it won't give you that our
value that's to turn that diagnostic on
so subscribe to the channel check out
more math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to seeing in future videos I'll
talk to you soon